so
i we were talking about race a little
bit before um and does it bother you
basically
that 79 of abortion clinics are in
america or in the black and the brown
communities and black women are three
times more likely to get an abortion
than white women and planned parenthood
was founded by a woman who wanted to
eradicate like the black race so she
decided to put these planned parenthoods
in like black communities
in order and market to black women in
order to like to basically market
abortions to them
and and then um that basically the black
population would be double today if it
wasn't for abortion in the us
i'm sorry it's just when they provide um
absolutely abortion yeah so the woman
that started it she she believed in like
like eradicated
race yeah basically and so she said
we're gonna market like planned
parenthood in in black neighborhoods
and basically
now black women are three times more
likely to get an abortion and the black
population would be double today if in
the u.s if it wasn't for abortion so it
kind of worked
yeah i'm uncomfortable with the idea of
eugenicists
has had um speaking wrong language now
have been successful and
okay sorry
i've got a really bad voice today so i
might whisper i don't know if
whispering's better no whispering is way
worse speak into
so
i'm uncomfortable that someone that had
that kind of plan
had succeeded in that kind of plan in a
sense but i do think that abortion
um is still valid and people still need
to need that option and it isn't what it
is it isn't the same as it was in the
past so now it's not just for black
women it's not targeted just a black
woman it's available to all races and
all people but i do feel like there's
still the history in that culture maybe
of abortion or go into planned
parenthood or in impoverished areas or
typically systematically oppressed areas
where abortion is like the only option
that's marketed to those people you know
i mean i'm uncomfortable with that but
i'm not uncomfortable that there's a
choice
because i want people to be able to
choose um what they do with their bodies
at the end of the day i'm uncomfortable
though eugenicist has had successfully
done that in a sense it makes me
uncomfortable my my question is if black
women are having more abortions than
white women
in these areas
is that because
they're falling pregnant more
that is my question is it as opposed to
they're more likely to get an abortion
if they do fall pregnant as opposed to
the amount of people who do because then
i think we've got another argument again
about if if the majority of people who
are impoverished in america within these
communities are black
then
that is another reason why more black
women would be falling pregnant and as
well if a lot of black men in those
communities commit crime because poverty
different reasons you know
systemically oppressed
then is that why these women are also
then not statistically more likely to be
sleeping with offenders and things like
that like for me those also that's a
really good connection that you've made
there i didn't get the last bit yeah i
didn't understand so are you saying
so wait so you think that um
if there's more offenders in your
community statistically you're more
likely to have sex with an offender okay
because of the higher probability you'll
have sex with an offender it does a lot
more in your community no i so i meant
like you were asking about the abortion
rates uh yes sorry so um is it the that
if you took the same
uh so if you did it as a ratio basically
of like um
uh black women
are more likely to have an abortion if
they fall pregnant compared or is it a
case of more black women have abortions
because more black women are falling
pregnant
i think i'm not 100 sure so this could
be wrong but from what i understand and
guys let me know in the chat sometimes
the chat be like factual yeah um but i
think i think it's black women are more
likely to have an abortion i don't think
the falling pregnant rates are different
okay
i would i would be interested to know
yeah
yeah i think that would make a
difference
like that that would just completely
change
like if it would depend it would really
depend on which
statistics is more valuable it makes me
more comfortable about the idea that
someone that had created that in mind i
think that is
so do you think like now in 2022 like
because i'd imagine if nike was founded
as like they they wanted to eliminate
the black race like people would be in
an uproar but for some reason like
planned parenthood gets a pass when
they're they're doing that
yeah the black population would be
doubled like that's crazy i know what
you mean by that i think i think with it
being a choice so no one is like oh
pearl you go to planned parenthood right
now like you get it like it's you have a
choice in going there um but i think it
is something to
to explore um outside of this and also
see how true these statistics are
because oftentimes they are like skewed
and i'm not saying that they have to be
100 wrong but often times especially
when representing black people they are
not accurate um
and so i i just think it's something to
be explored but if people are like going
there willingly i don't necessarily feel
bad because
likely they're in the situation where
they're not going to be able to take
care of these kids so now you're saying
oh the population could be double but
are you also then saying that it could
be double of
people that are not going to be loved
that are not going to be like uh
instilled like a value of life like not
saying that their life isn't valuable
but they're not going to be taught any
principles that are going to like make
or break their life so now you're saying
oh it could be doubled but in this sense
they're not gonna be nurtured so they're
gonna be more criminals and now you're
gonna say oh yeah like all the black
people are criminals well you just said
you wanted half of them to be here like
double do you get what i'm saying yeah
also on the topic of
redemption and our short-term memory
um
you can also make this argument for the
same of companies like hugo boss who
made this nazi staff for nazis and lots
of other german companies uh chanel coco
chanel was a a
yeah it was a nazi sympathizer like the
days that were in the past yeah like
completely different people running
games that kind of thing but do you
think it's like
like okay it's one thing right if like
people
choose to get an abortion i understand
it's still a choice but but they're
marketing this to young girls like
they're they're specific they
specifically pick
lower income communities and market it
to those communities like isn't isn't
that
yeah they talk about that how do they do
they have tv ads and stuff that they
only show in these communities yeah like
i want to know well
i i want to say it's either 69 or 70 of
all the abortion clinics are located in
those communities and then and then and
then on top of that like like margaret
um like the lady who started it had like
a a marketing plan written out talking
about how she wanted to market it but
like how did she do i've never actually
seen now that you've said i've never
actually seen a an abortion mark
marketing scheme i've never seen it ever
or right anything i do i've no
necessary advert in that sense but i
think as far as placement and just you
saying that like
it really is in my head thinking because
obviously i'm the only one aside from
pearl that's from america and thinking
about the like
uh like planned parenthood's um
that i know of
i don't i'm pretty sure it's not the
only one but the only one that i can
think of is like in a lower income area
um with
an immense amount of marginalized people
so
it's i don't think it's just there but i
think it is something to explore like i
think overall it is a but it's not the
only place you can get an abortion
they don't only serve like that's my
question to you no no guys one at a time
please i'm saying like
it's kind of like when you think about
it it's kind of messed up because it's
like then only the rich like it's almost
and i don't think people directly mean
this but in a way it's saying that only
like rich lives are more valuable
because that's where the planned
parenthood
get an abortion at is
parenthood or can you get it at like a
doctor like yeah this is my question
because that's a case of it's not just
about pumpkin don't need planned
parenthood because you have money to
afford to go private you can go to your
doctor that's in your own area that's
all yeah
but while we're mentioning this thank
you for bringing that up um a lot of um
white people will especially like say in
politics will
say
say i'm a senator and you're my daughter
well i don't i'm saying oh no abortions
no abortions i'm sure it's not letting
you be known for your abortion right so
i'm gonna take you privately and no no
one's knowing about this abortion and
we're not utilizing these government
services i'm going to my privatized
health care but that's that's more than
that so you can have five people but the
average white person isn't making that
kind of money like like the average one
person isn't in that income bracket
where they're in a politician situation
where their height like that's not uh a
wealth advantage like generational
wealth but it's a thing you have to
acknowledge that
sure sure generational wealth is a thing
yeah so you're going to have more
resources and more money like a lot of
black people are starting their
generation one two generations ago as
far as like their money whereas white
people can go back to the beginning of
slavery or like settling in america
so yeah you can look at it on a
different account necessarily because
the majority of people in the us came
from like after slavery but still even
the ones like that came like towards the
end they were able to benefit off of the
end of slavery and these different jobs
that were repurposed after slavery and
able to like start working like black
people were not able to like
sustain a living or earn
in this sense like white people at the
end of the day are like
america is built to benefit white people
right so at the end of day
you won't see it because it's not meant
to be like hey
you guys are being good like treat it
better it's it's very why don't you say
this is like contributing to the problem
though if they're marketing abortions to
low-income neighborhoods and they're
basically eradicating
available there but they're not like
marketing you're right you're right it's
not only available there but you don't
think it's a little bit messed up
like that that a huge like i just i
don't know how i think it said this
especially like what's messed up about
having
okay accessible healthcare in a poorer
area
no that's not what's messed up but that
is
because what i'm getting from it is that
it's messed up the fact that sorry
that um
it's messed up the fact that um the
whole thing was built to eradicate that
face that's what i'm well it's a mess
that's messed up to do that and they're
doing it that's what's messed up that's
my stuff but you could say okay we have
new people in charge but they're still
doing the same thing
and let's talk about it from the
perspective okay black people are living
in poor areas and that's where planned
parenthood is for people that don't have
access to expensive healthcare or
privatized healthcare but you can still
get an abortion somewhere else
and it can the location of that abortion
could be in hospital in an affluent area
is that being marketed to rich people
like that logic i don't think it i don't
think it holds well because planned
parenthood is the number one provider of
abortions in the u.s they don't know
public private abortions are they but
it's number one because obviously it's
the cheapest option
it's it's the most available option i
don't think that because of the
availability in the location it makes it
more
marketing
i can understand both sides and like at
the end of the day i feel like just
overall abortion is someone's choice
like no i don't most cases people are
not being forced like i feel like
maybe a few years back but most times
now people are getting an abortion by
their own merit so i like i i do get the
argument but
you're choosing to do that so
it's your choice at the end of the day